[Musique]
on a proposé donc une après midi autour
de l'intimé au xviiie siècle avec
différents ateliers une médiation en
fait dans les appartements et puis
ensuite on a plusieurs partenariats qui
sont vraiment géniaux notamment avec
l'osmothèque donc le conservatoire de
parfum de versailles et avec lequel on
va travailler qui nous ont fait des
prêts de matériel pour proposer pour
essayer les fragrances d'époque
on aura aussi une harpiste clara
isambert qui vient proposer une
prestation sur une harpe restaurée du
xviiie on est des étudiants de l'ue vs
cube qui feront qui sont toutes dans le
même master donc de projets culturels
internationaux et on fait partie de
cette association culture sans frontière
et on monte donc des différents
événements on est quatre on essaye de
faire venir un public varié après en
fait les étudiants c'est pas forcément
le public qui sera le plus fin qui est
le plus habitué à fréquenter le musée
lambinet donc le but aussi c'est de
faire venir des étudiants et présenté
voilà un nouveau format l'événement est
gratuit
après il faut payer là le tarif d'entrée
au musée
donc c'est 6 euros et puis en tarif
réduit ses 4 euros donc c'est le 1er
février de 14h à 18h30
14h à 18h pardon à versailles donc au
musée lambinet